[Music]
well tonight family friends they are
remembering a man killed earlier this
week in what police have said was a case
of road rage happening on tuesday
afternoon on the east side of the valley
73 year old marlon smith died wednesday
of his injuries
victoria saha spoke with smith's best
friend and he reflects on a man lost too
soon to really a senseless crime
what started as road rage left
73-year-old marlon smith
dead when a driver ran him over after
the two got into a confrontation right
here on boulder highway and desert inn
tonight his best friend has words for
the person responsible metro police say
a driver of a suburban cut smith off on
tuesday
smith honked his horn a passenger in the
suburban threw a beer can at smith's
jeep
smith got out of his car getting into an
argument with the passenger of the
suburban
then police say the passengers got back
in the vehicle and the driver
ran smith over and took off the people
in the suburban were stopped
but no word yet on charges they faced
and their names have not been released
larry gandy says smith was his best
friend
to be run over by two guys in the street
and left in the hot pavement to die
you know in front of his poor little
wife
is just disheartening there's there's no
punishment grave enough for these guys
police have yet to identify the
occupants in the suburban
gandhi says he and smith had a love for
motorcycles
he also says smith was a vietnam veteran
the man smith used to ride motorcycles
with will be hosting a ride
this saturday in honor of him reporting
from boulder highway and desert inn
victoria saha 8 news now
road rage and aggressive drivers really
a hot topic of discussion we reached out
to you on twitter have you seen
aggressive driving
recently on valley roads 84
say yes 16 say no you can join the
conversation tell us what you see on our
streets and freeways
let us know 8newsnow.com